I look like the evil baby what's up
y'all it's police' about a month ago I
saw this crazy video from this amazing
Brazilian hairstylist who is bringing
back my favorite trend the frosted tip I
asked around the office if anybody
wanted to give it a go and I have some
takers we're gonna go see them get their
tips frosted my hair says about me that
I watched a lot of anime in the 90s and
2000 I've been wanting to do something
to my hair since JT did it back in the
nineties why do you do mark like maybe
silver I don't know maybe like platinum
but I just like so as you can tell I'm
really nervous
my name is andreas honest honest and
this is the undressed Nastasia studio I
would hope that we're over any stigma
about men doing anything cosmetic we're
gonna prove everybody wrong by showing
them how it's done
frosty tips should be a good decade
since I've done them I've been wanting
to pull someone's hair through a cab for
quite a while now so this is gonna be
really exhilarating for me alright let's
get started
[Music]
I'm gonna get this a spiky as possible
because I'm gonna do a process called
shoe-shining
middle school be able to love this if
anything is this isn't even the Llosa
product I've ever had in my hair you get
really good Wi-Fi with it holy
hydropower channels it feels a little
bit like I'm in a makeover portion of
how to be a kpop star it's the big
reveal this is the most fun right here
oh my god I don't have any words okay I
can look now
a throwback style to it but we'll make
it our own version of it I kind of want
to shave so that the emphasis is on the
hair on my head and not put in my mouth
it's my 19th dream even better than I
thought it could be I'm so stoked I
can't wait to see what everybody says I
can't wait to see what my mother says if
they'll take me I'm going on tour with
the Backstreet Boys
I think van and I might actually have a
little bit of competition it looks so
good what did you do the whole time we
were prepping for this video we're
talking about V there's a JT or the guy
fieri and then they take that cap off
and I am 100% Guy Fieri it's been an
interesting kind of process with how I
dress myself in the morning I'm not sure
what possessed me to do all denim today
maybe it's the hair it's fun it's cool
to see people's reactions to it I like
it it's like all of your middle school
dreams came true can I touch it
[Laughter]
Dean would you ever do frosted tips we
think as a society that anything that's
about appearance is inherently feminine
I think it's something that we should
all really strip down like what we've
done to my hair I'm glad we didn't
really go all the way there we made it
look like I still belong in 2017
thankfully I am at the forefront of the
trend I'm gonna be the profit for
frosted tips in 2017
[Music]